when you train your neural network is
important to initialize the weights
randomly for logistic regression it was
okay to initialize the weights to zero
but for a neural network of initializer
wastes the parameters to all 0 and then
apply gradient descent it won't work
let's see why so you have here two input
features so n 0 is equal to 2 and 2
hidden units so N 1 is equal to 2 and so
the matrix associated with a hidden
layer or W 1 is going to be 2 by 2 let's
say that you initialize it to all zeros
0 0 0 0 2 by 2 matrix and let's say P 1
is also equal to 0 0 turns out
initializing the bias terms B to 0 is
actually okay but initializing W to all
zeros is a problem so the problem with
this formal initialization is that for
any example you give it you have that a
1 1 and a 1 2 will be equal all right so
this activation and this activation
would be sync because both of these
hidden units are computing exactly the
same function and then when you compute
back propagation it turns out that D Z 1
1 and D Z 1 2 will also be the same
color by symmetry all right both of
these settings units will initialize the
same way technically for what I'm saying
I'm assuming that the outgoing weights
are also identical so that W 2 is equal
to 0 0 but if you initialize the neural
network this way then this hidden unit
and this hidden unit are completely
identical so they're completely
sometimes you say they're completely
symmetric which just means that the
computing exactly the same function and
by kind of a proof by induction it turns
out that after every single iteration of
training you're two hidden units are
still confusing exactly the same
function
since also the show that DW will be a
matrix that looks like this where every
row takes on the same value so we
perform a weight update so you perform
when you perform a weight update w1 gets
updated as w1 minus alpha times DW you
find that w1 after every iteration will
have you know the first row equal to the
second row so it's possible to construct
a proof by induction that if you
initialize all the ways all the values
of W to 0 then because both hidden units
start off computing the same function
and both hidden units have the same
influence on the output unit then after
one iteration that same statement is
still true the two hidden units are
still symmetric and therefore by
induction after two iterations three
iterations and so on no matter how long
you train in your network both hidden
units are still computing exactly the
same function and so in this case
there's really no point to having more
than one hidden unit because they're all
computing the same thing and of course
for larger neural networks less you have
three features and maybe a very large
number of hidden units a similar
argument works to show that we're gonna
network like this because I won't drawn
all the edges if you initialize the ways
to zero then all of your hidden units
are symmetric and no matter how long you
run gradient descent they'll all
continue to compute exactly the same
function so that's not helpful because
you want two different hidden units to
compute different functions the solution
to this is to initialize your parameters
randomly so here's what you do you can
set W 1 equals NP about random dot R and
n this generates a Gaussian random
variable to 2 and then usually you
multiply this by a very small number
such as 0.01 so you initialize it to
very small random values and then be um
it turns out that B does not have this
symmetry problem what's called the
symmetry breaking problem
so is okay to initialize B to just zeros
because so long as WS initialize
randomly you start top of the different
hidden units computing different things
and so you no longer have this some
symmetry breaking problem and then
similarly for w2 you can initialize that
randomly and b2 you can initialize that
to zero so you might be wondering you
know where did this constant come from
and why is it 0.01 why not put the
number 100 or 1000 turns out that we
usually prefer to initialize the ways to
get very small random values because um
if you're using a satanic or sigmoid
activation function or if you have a
sigmoid even just at the output layer if
the weights are too large then when you
compute the activation values remember
that Z 1 is equal to W 1 X plus B and
then on a 1 is the activation function
applied to Z 1 so if W is very big Z
will be very big or at least some values
of Z will be either very large or very
small and so in that case you're more
likely to end up at these flat parts of
the 10h function or the sigmoid function
where the slope of the gradient is very
small meaning that gradient descent
would be very slow and so learning was
very slow so just a recap if W is too
large you're more likely to end up even
at the very start of training with very
large values of Z which causes your 10 a
to a sigmoid activation function to be
saturated on the slowing down learning
if you don't have any Sigma naught NH
activation functions throughout your
neural network this is less of an issue
but if you're doing binary consultation
and your output unit is a sigmoid
function then you know you just don't
want the initial parameters to be too
large so that's why multiplying by 0.01
would be something reasonable to try or
any other small number and same for W 2
it can be a random random I guess this
would be 1 by 2 in this example times
0.01 Sigma s there so finally it turns
out that sometimes they can be better
constants than 0.01 when you're training
a neural network with just one hidden
layer this is a relatively shallow you
know network without too many hidden
layers set into 0.01 will probably work
ok but when you're training a very very
deep neural network then you might want
to pick a different constant in 0.001
and in next week's material we'll talk a
little bit about how and when you might
want to choose a different constant than
0.01 but either way it will usually end
up being a relatively small number so
that's it so this week videos you now
know how to set up a neural network of a
hidden layer
initialize the parameters make
predictions using forward prop as well
as compute derivatives and it's been
gradient descent using back prop so that
you should be able to do the quizzes as
well as disease programming exercises
best of luck with that I hope you have
fun with pro exercise and look forward
to seeing you in the week school
materials